des animations pour la bonne cause le
monde associatif mort patients étaient
mobilisés pour cette 33e édition du
téléthon
plusieurs initiatives étaient proposées
au public au gymnase de la malle me
donne de l'argent
j'ai une amie qui en famille aux pattes
et je suis particulièrement
sensibiliser arts martiaux gymnastique
ou encore initiation handfauteuil une
opération de solidarité qui réunit
chaque année de nombreux bénévoles
faut pas croire les bénévoles du
téléthon sont pas forcément des gens ils
sont touchés famille allemand ou
amicales m'empare par ces maladies mais
par des gens simplement qu'on a envie de
faire quelque chose pour les autres et
particulièrement pour les enfants
[Musique]
changement d'ambiance à villepreux pour
ce téléthon le public a pu faire le
plein de sensations dans des supercars
une animation proposée par le moto club
de philippe rue et c'est l'occasion de
première en dehors de faire partager
notre passion de pouvoir faire
bénéficier à toute personne d'avoir
l'occasion de monter dans une super
carte on a l'occasion de monter dedans
et de rouler avec
avec ces baptêmes mis leur ont ainsi pu
être récoltés en faveur de la recherche
contre les maladies génétiques
parmi les autres temps forts de cette
33e édition des démonstrations de
capoeira ou encore un défi rameurs de 24
heures le tissu associatif est très
créatif à on a les artistes qui exposent
donc toutes leurs créations nettes peu
plus de 500 bénévoles je pense depuis un
an pour être à ce week end festif pour
le téléthon avec une fréquentation
supérieure à l'année dernière le bilan
est d'ores et déjà positive pour l'afm
téléthon de villepreux